for most of us living on our own is a
rite of passage it's part of becoming an
adult
but for many in our special needs
community it's a goal that's just out of
reach
well next week opportunity village will
unveil its attempt to help adults with
disabilities live on their own
i got a sneak peek and i wasn't the only
one
i remember when this was just a dirt lot
for corey gerhart the dream has come
true now there's
houses being built today he saw his new
home for the first time
the first time he'll live on his own i
was telling my mom that i wanted to live
on my own and stuff for a long time
and now i'm actually going to live in
this nice this nice apartment
and stuff so oh man
a little overwhelming yeah gerhart is
one of the first tenants at betty's
village
it's the first housing project built by
opportunity village
the adults with special needs it employs
can now live independently
gerhard's mother is i'm speechless sort
of ready to let him leave
so beautiful you've been excited to live
at betty's village
70 adults most with special needs will
live here
for many it'll be their first time in a
home of their own everyone needs to have
a little bit of independence
rihanna massio is responsible for
running betty's village
people with disabilities can do it on
their own and you just have to give them
that opportunity
and with the right supports in place i
mean you can do whatever you want
ov will have staff on site to help the
tenants
there's a gym a pool just like any other
apartment complex
this is a community the next chapter in
my life is happening
corey and his mother are still adjusting
then it hit me
how i'm going to feel with him not being
there and
i it took my breath away but he's just a
phone call away
that's actually my house corey can i
give you a hug
sure this is actually my house i'm so
excited welcome home
dude well now we should point out we i
shot that story a couple of weeks ago
they've made a lot of progress in the
construction
since then opportunity villages holding
a grand opening next week tenants will
start moving in soon afterwards
and the nonprofit says it's considering
building more housing units like this
for its clients in the future